The correct answer and again, this might be a little bit subjective,
but I think in this case it's not very subjective.
Is showing tractability is actually easier than showing intractability, and the reason for that is
that if you want to show that a problem has a polynomial time algorithm,
then all you need to do is come up with that algorithm.
Now, that might be very hard, but nevertheless, once you have found a single algorithm
for a problem that has polynomial running time, then you're done.
You have shown that this problem is tractable.
On the other hand, if you want to show that a problem is intractable--what you have to show is
any possible algorithm, so not only the algorithms that you can come up with,
not only the algorithms that somebody else can come up--any algorithm that somebody
could come up with at any point in time must still have exponential running time.
Just stating a single algorithm or even a hundred algorithms is not enough to show intractability.
For that reason, I think show intractability is in a way much easier than showing intractability.